what would allow
me to to deceive myself get the result
the apparent result
without actually getting the result
you didn't step forward
no that is the result somehow predicting
okay but we they couldn't let go any
time so
that wouldn't be what's going on here
the stress is not big enough that's
exactly it okay you got it
on her drew a little better
there you go
okay but that's not what he was doing
okay
so
he's he's driving and you kind of it's
hard for them to tell because you're
trying to push me with your
base you see do you get it i i want you
to
show
uh
your body pushing okay oh do you see
that
get more bracing if you want you know
what i mean like
you understand
that's what i'm grabbing
more drive your legs
okay
what are the two things you expect is
going to happen
by increasing the stress
you're getting pushed backwards you're
going to get pushed over backwards
so ronnie you're gonna do the same level
same exact level
go
okay oh i'm not even in the ballpark you
get it
okay or the other one is
you're gonna go forward because you're
gonna break something okay got it so we
have to up the
stress to assess more correctly okay go
higher
okay
so um
this is not about being so powerful that
he can't move me
you always want to move fighting is
about moving okay
but
being tasked with not being moved
without bracing angles
is symptomatic
of
taking energy
internally through my body and down to
the ground
do you understand that
okay i'm gonna do different things with
this skill
and standing still and not being pushed
over that's not one of them
okay
you you could you don't it's not even
about stability
it's about where energy goes
okay do you understand so
uh for example don't move anymore
i'm going to do that same energy
transference
and put it in my hand
okay
and it has nothing to do with me
standing still
okay
that fist is much
heavier than that fist
got it and this punch boom
is much heavier than
that punch okay
likewise
this
edb nugget
is much lighter
than this
do you get it i'm doing different things
with that same skill okay
to get ourselves here it's
psych it's
psychophysiological
it's not pure body
and it's not pure mind okay
so
to start with it's easier if you
organize your body a particular way
because it's ultimately an energetic
utilization of my body mind
it's not dependent upon form
but it's easier to start with a form
okay and more importantly it's easier to
not start with other forms
you see this is never going to do it
this bracing angle is not it
nor is this stance here
that's not it
so
you're going to get tired but you didn't
really work out too hard today so don't
worry
okay
um
my knees are bent versus straight or
locked
got it
my stance is not on the tight rope
put your feet
hip width apart
some of you don't realize that's not
your hips
do you see this
here
here's my hips
hip width apart
your head counts
this is not it you're never going to get
it this way never
okay
this chin has to be down
and this crown in your head has to be
the high point not the
top of your head this is not going to
work
um
your pelvis can you don't want to do
this with your back point your pelvis
down you're taking it all in your back
it's a bracing angle
okay
the flat of my back
my back is going to be flat not this way
and not this way some of you are either
one
this way and this way you can't do it
you feel the weakness in there okay you
push degrees
okay
so
fly
at first
for your mind if your mind is small
it's going to be hard to do
so your mind is big
big big
if you have to use your imagination
touch something behind him just keep
reaching for your body will acclimate to
that imagery okay
and you can come on you push
push use two hands then okay
he's pushing drive drive drive with your
legs okay at any point he wants to let
go
right
don't go flying
okay
so i'm gonna go around and i'm gonna
correct your various postures and your
imagination to kind of help
okay
all right let's try it go
hey in the beginning as i said this is
trying to get you in the ballpark if you
pay attention
uh
you start to disorganize
these four corners
okay
but you have to think of them not
two-dimensionally
so
this is wrong this is wrong this is
wrong do you get it they have to stay
in that place okay so let's say i'm here
and i you can feel the ground right and
then as he starts to push do you see
this this thing starting to turn this
thing's starting to turn this thing's
starting to drop and now it's very hard
to ground and as he increases the stress
i cannot do it
again at the beginning levels that's
what will happen of course uh once he he
pushes he pushes right
none of that is important none of that
is important you could do uh
goofy stuff none of it is important okay
but at the beginning it is important
you got it
okay so where i want you to put your
effort
is not in um
not being pushed back
and not even in not going forward i want
you to try to hold
those four corners
you got it hold them hold them hold it
as he starts to increase
you
you just keep those four corners in
place okay you understand don't let it
start dipping and start dismantling that
organization that's where you put your
effort and energy okay try
so i do have to hold those corners but
now what you guys are doing is you don't
have midfoot weight
you're you're back here okay
again
as when you when you get when you
understand it energetically you don't
need mid-foot weight i can be on my
heels and it'll still work okay but at
the beginning
you can't
you're asking too much okay
um
so
mid-foot
midfoot
right there
is where
you position these four corners
so that
your weight
is dropping on that thing on that point
do you get it not on my heel do you see
that
not on my arch
not on the outside of my foot and not on
my toes
got it it goes all my weight
goes right on that spot
and his energy
goes right in that spot too and i hold
these four corners just like you were
so that that spot is getting heavier and
heavier and heavier i hold those corners
not letting it do this stuff do you see
not letting my shoulders go back
not trying to push
just hold the corners
boom
into that spot don't let it go to your
heels hold the corners hold the corners
okay so you're gonna combine the corner
drill
with the midfoot vectoring on the back
foot in this case okay
all right try
getting better okay
so uh again if we're gonna assess we're
trying to increase the stress at that
time to make sure that our form is
more uh accurately
manifested so we're gonna do another one
okay so uh this one i don't have that
racing angle at all do you see that so
he's gonna push and it's gonna go into
my
uh same mid foot same four corner drill
okay but what i'm going to do is i'm
going to take it off myself
okay it's no different than if he takes
it off
i don't go flying
so
if i'm here he's pushing driving when i
take it off i shouldn't go flying
onto my toes i didn't take that energy
keep it down and then we're going to
yawn it back into place
i should not go bouncing off do you see
that so it's the same drill but just
done a little bit more dynamically so
pull here and hop and pop
what would be wrong is of course i can't
do it
or two when i go off i fail forward or
three when i go forward i push myself
off okay so all of those different
energies
okay so
he's driving driving driving driving
driving
that's not what i did was it
okay
so he's driving
it's a quick change
in direction do you see that not a
gradual change
it's quick
quick
okay